we related and must be considered as a
functioning unit the game technology
gives us a missile control we're live
live game people had to give me a brief
moment the games industry has been an
arms race developing real-time
technologies such as virtual avatars
natural human computer interfaces data
analytic tools online technologies it
looks fine that's on our end earth
that's on someone else's what if we
could go further and give people the
ability to see engage with and perhaps
even overcome
over the next few months and years we
will be sharing our approach publishing
our findings and growing our team the
project will grow in complexity as we
tackle harder and are the problems
solution however we do believe that by
focusing our efforts on what we can do
now and collaborate someone's audios
tacos we can kick-start what's it why is
this glitchy no that's what I want to
the streams glitching I've done plenty
of these to know how these work it's not
supposed to do that what's up Matt uh
what's up graphic uh icon you can see
you on YouTube
I'm live there's people in the chat it's
not my fault you don't know how to find
it the challenges what you face I'm
gonna mute this for right now alright
let me double check this everything's
good there yeah we kind of hike man go
ahead and talk death
they can hear you now but I don't know
what they can hear you after cuz you you
are kind of low man you little low why
is it low though that's what I'm trying
to figure eight I have no clue I think
this is a you problem let me go ahead
and put this up to the people on good ol
you on Twitter so they know that we're
streaming I'm just I'm curious man I
I've been told by a couple people to not
get my high me hyped but you know we're
gonna have to see we want to see now I
got to send something to uh all right
there
well I mean you so right to get hyped
yeah I don't need to turn this all the
way down I can't do this we might go to
YouTube because it's it's glitching over
here on on mixer man I thought mixer I
think I'm going to go to give me a brief
second you guys I'm gonna go ahead and
switch to YouTube because mixer for some
reason all my ends just not working Xbox
so they should probably be one with yeah
they're doing it for the Xbox for
Channel
oh mixer has like crazy stuff going on
I mean you YouTube has this
yeah that's the same thing mixes go no
I'll make sure it was it was it was like
mute like something that was actually
going on there was some kind of video
playing about the adaptive controller
yeah it was an advert I think like
behind the scenes all right send me that
the link to the actual the URL to the
actual park to the to the stream and
right now we're waiting for the right
and for some of the other lures kids
smooth will be joining us too
yeah but he'll be a little late I send
it the link that's good he'll be a
little late you guys got some people
coming now figured I'd go live a little
early they show Age of Empires for
I'm trying to finish this before this
thing starts because so so out of
curiosity what do you expect
I expect to brilliant new IPs to new IP
now who's the new IPS gonna be in are
they gonna be good new IPs because there
are such thing as bad new IPs
there is but one of them's obsidian
that's a guaranteed good game now
weapons if it's a Monopoly board game
obsidian don't well I mean they haven't
ever made anything that is not an RPG so
it'd be something new I mean something
no a real house I mean I'd imagine it'd
be able to pull off a damn good RPG
Monopoly game though I don't know why
but I've always enjoyed this this theme
that our inside Xbox has got going on
they posted something that doesn't
really work and no one cares about
anymore I noticed on this inside Xbox
logo the millennium wheel the big wheel
in the background no one cares about
there anymore and I don't even think it
works
I hear the rumor as well but I'm not
gonna say anything I heard some stuff
too that I've been asked by the same
oh I like this beep I don't know what
what's up in our lives
I'm sorry if I've been missing the UH
the chat a little bit what's up Nova
tech money Scott nice graphic god
Megatron I was getting a little bit
things took in care of hopefully that
would be the end of that but we've never
done a reaction so people will be
joining throughout the podcast what's up
Charles R oh here we go it's a better
stop
of course they open this up will for
tonight why does that not surprise me
you know what you know what I'm so sick
and tired of this fort night stuff man
it never goes anywhere
well it's sponsored by fortnight so hey
[Music]
what's what's going on schools right now
we're not gonna really have any face
cameras on the screen but the next time
we do reaction I promise you will be a
little more professional than this we
just decided to do this like yesterday
or the day before so there wasn't a lot
of time to have something professionally
made I like that that was good I like
that
let's go
[Music]
that's kid that's child abuse right
there
let's be real here that little kid got
wrecked the moment that stuck kids are
better go ham
do they got me height man I hate this
because if it sucks I'd like to go in on
them what's up Charles they're having a
real big focus on Star Wars we're
shipping Star Wars game so it's been
crazy it's magical
but you know huge shout out to all
respawn especially to the to my team the
Jedi fallen order team responds
definitely the best company you know you
know they say either to die here or
become the villain there's nothing like
it it's a massive honour and stay it's
day one it's something that we never
took for granted all right and we know
you bought some amazing gameplay for us
to check out like an what fans got to
expect
well we've got you know amazing story in
this game we were able to put together
some a great cast with actors like
Cameron some general general dad a
fantastic I've butchered your name so
you guys should know this by our own
droid with bd1 which is like what's up
CD my true could go on and on right it's
amazing we have to check this out slice
celebrate the launch and check out this
trailer here we go
trust only in the force this looks good
okay I'm telling you man III I'm leaning
more towards this than Pokemon now cuz
Pokemon night look in that hot right now
this gives me like a star was unleashed
fellas yeah this was a phase need to
look at all that III behind it seems
when we saw it
what's up drunken what's up Brandon yeah
I think they're going away from that
dude I really do like gates what up what
up the celebration has just begun we
could be a little less formal of these
[Applause]
[Music]
Battletoads gears they doing this right
man I'm not gonna love it what's it
heated heavy I like that name
mm-hmm no bud what's up
he said broke David and now it's not
Pocket Watch in heated heavy you guys
only consider a pocket watch and the
other way around King had to go pick up
his kids
unfortunately he couldn't make it from
real life stuff I don't see any
contrived fake applause is just too much
[Applause]
star watching I think the Matt booty
first virtual thing has her voice is a
little strong we got King David and I'm
real broke broke thing slave
oh my god rare the studio behind sea of
thieves but Louise I hear you and
another team inside aware have been
quietly crafting on another world can
you tell us a little bit about it well
okay I've been lucky enough to be
working at rare for about this is a JD I
like that accent I can get down with
that axe to it you know they gotta have
some friends minimal cringe please we
should be seeing the game already
exactly too much faces over I'm already
seeing too many faces oh she said
players everyone I don't like that I
like when people say everyone can play
this game
[Music]
[Music]
world premiere world premiere world
premiere gotta love that voice oh is the
rare man gotta love it let's just be
trash oh my god die selves dev is a pile
of good already looking spooky let's see
he has a minecraft song going on
nope never mind that changed real quick
[Music]
your heart said please be good just kind
of reminds me of arc no remember the
game we saw out of packs the the one
that we liked was like a Zelda clone and
Dark Souls mmm they came I just recently
came out to Nick no the tunic should be
in this somewhere it was like Rising
Stars games I believe this is gonna be
another little shared adventure boobs
but I could already tell it in the coop
I see it's not a chick it looks nice the
three players
[Music]
decay of logos that's what it looks like
it looks like a three blitz like a co-op
decay of logos I've seen a weapon for a
while ever while okay it's rare what do
you expect for release sit in hell
Steve's a give promotional credit and a
chance at winning a year subscription to
Xbox game parts ultimate my show channel
I'm with you brother next journey which
begins with ever wild what's it like to
show off every while for the first time
and how else is Xbox game studios
showing up today I thought that trailer
was amazing I mean the visuals are so
new I feed people wanted that it's
really just a magical window into
something new that's being created at
right thanks for the light safe drive
Studios has more than one team under the
same roof and so it's great to see a new
team with new Aiki free oh they just
openly admit it everyone's got multiple
teeth with the team that will continue
working on CFDs across all of our
studios we've really shifted from a
focus on growth and acquisition moving
on to execution and delivery and really
delivering on the promise of these great
games that includes our publishing team
that's why I left make sure the projects
with independent creators who will bring
exclusive content wow she went okay we
got singing a billion kids Mugu be here
probably the next couple minutes what's
a real tangible benefit that game pass
gives to you to more new IP but the
great thing about games is that it
really empowers me
what's so great at which is creating
great games whether it's a large-scale
game or a small passion project both of
those can exist inside Xbox it's also
brought a whole new audience to some of
our games it might be a game that
someone did he's sweatin like a mother
it's really brought a whole new audience
to our games and a good example of that
is outer world from our obsidian studio
[Applause]
right go see already it's found a great
audience inside game yeah thank you so
much going to talk to us as well I'm
really excited to everything come back
also we ain't see any entertainment
brought us out of worlds but we also now
have an Xbox another Xbox game Studios
reveal of another title from obsidian
showcasing those multiple teams let's
take a lords get it
Dane things get it let's get it big
awesome let's see what it do
there's your spot here's your moment
this for me let me get this come on
I believe a survival game
got a baseball
you need to be confused not excited
because this doesn't look this is the
animation was not it though the
animation on that on the run is not it
the swim didn't look so bad
hey stupid adjust this with their value
basket game fans get your unity out of
consolidate say I'm start like I think
we might have to cut like that might be
it now like no this is absurd
give what this is showing me is they
letting people rock with a little
passion projects to say way ninja
Terry's doing bleeding edge you know Sam
and that that's cool and all and it's a
game previews but this was not this is
not the one I was looking for they they
done shot two bullets I did not I was
not feeling whatsoever
[Applause]
you think yeah so grounded has actually
been a development for a little over a
year it's a small team headed up by Adam
brenneke who is the executive producer
on dead fire the whole team is just
really into survival games and we want
to see what we can bring to the genre
it's something that was in production
before we became part of Microsoft but
once Microsoft saw it they're really
supportive okay good that's the excuse
that's the excuse I'm running what did
you did this before Microsoft do the bag
it does look like James they're just not
cancelling yes that's a youtube trailer
on the old grounded as an Xbox
this unique what does he mean Xbox
players were shrunk down to the size
banana brandy our project director he
was pretty excited about this idea that
he ran over to Fergus our studio head
and said let's do this he gave us the
green light and we put together a small
team and started to just flex our
creative muscles and within a month we
knew we had some special so we just we
just been running with it
and talking about something special we
know they sing
schools yeah so like we did with pillars
one and pillars two we want to involve
the commotion so it's just a tiny teeny
as possible
after that we will going into game
preview on the inside of always one
incentive this coming spring and we've
been pretty excited about going to game
pass because we feel that only evolved
even more the community to help shape
this game along our side our team at
obsidian ace and what's even cooler is
that born it's here EXO 19 will be able
to play ground it's over the next few
days Robby Josh thank you so much for
giving okay Xbox fans to celebrate EXO
19 for fans around the world we are
running home moving along so when some
our biggest tales and it starts right
whatever watch on only you can get
between 20 and 70 percent off some of
your favorite Xbox games including sea
of thieves anniversary edition gears 5
Ultimate Edition Borderlands 3 super
deluxe edition FIFA 20 champions Edition
and addition the game the edition
Edition and more than 20 other fan
favorites coming up later we have the
latest on bleeding edge s power bill
sponsor and more game reveals like this
one
world premiere yes do something Oh
cel-shaded Red Dead toward the light
shout out to shout to tell-tale red dead
no shouts is true by far what I miss how
long has been on strike came here at the
right time
they shot they two bullets us though
ain't impressed oh this looks cool this
actually looks good is it is it like
text on there looking like I'm John with
taxes it like ex-con or this I don't
think it's a turn I like the aesthetic
I'm a little biased or just one good hey
Koji was right y'all only care about
shooting you know what's funny we were
big fans of destiny
CD back fire policy we check yeah have
it mr. Dale they better got some like
bomb crazy studio announcement or
something because I'm already deeming
this with an L later who makes this raw
fury the people who are supposed to make
um might be the publishers that last
night
JD game I'm with you bro got your
migraine give us to deal see what state
became I don't notice oh oh there's like
I have no player review this game some
some dude this game has to play one on
Twitter my man said now you know she
need to do look like me oh you need to
do listener reviews okay I'm down I'm
down with that marketing whoever's there
with your party then I gotta pull that
off Wow
geez there's kid weight on here they now
a rare and obsidians new title already
yes I've seen it on remember remember
the cussing on here kids we're strong I
hope it's looking real smokey this will
be something I'll draw playing but it's
this is something I can make kids whose
mad eyes do it okay what to see who's
attached to this hetero Darrell said if
not enough dude bro shooters for you
attic look man I didn't hear who he said
said that this is not what the millions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe one after a certain market and yes
can you more about this yeah sure so
basically you can see the characters
with different skins and you actually
see that different emotes actually
playing it as well so that's for the
characters and also parts have different
types like we have even toilet car it's
available the whole is this whole show
go end up in the bushes
[Laughter]
all right mom's great I would love to
see some game playing from Lindsay with
her we've got cart Rider league's top to
eSports your Gregory would do is good
we're doing a mess oh yeah sure good so
what they're about to start is the speed
mode for the game basically whoa go on
deep dive this is the deep dive just
because they can do all the dedicatedly
not like this no not right a racing but
it does look nice though I'll tell you
this if this would have been like like a
twenty thirty player joint how they go
show this stuff when I showed the new IP
gameplay this is what's ready this is
something I can see me making kids be
very upset
[Music]
it's that pressure I still don't
understand why they're showing this
watch this be the only game this show
game play with which there's nothing
wrong with this game I don't have no
issue with the game but it's just like I
don't think they should have what this
and dad I'm looking forward to it well
thank you both so much for joining us we
really appreciate it
and a reminder the closed beta for cart
Rider Drift begins on December 5th is
ready getting ready to go
[Applause]
I loved interviewing us I gotta give
them the support I mean ninja theories
got a great heritage in making combat
action games so I wanted to carry that
forward and kind of combine it with my
passion money would look at spooky be my
laddie I told them they didn't listen to
me so it's a really interesting
combination and stuff it looks very
exciting and you've bought something
rather special with you today actually
interested in this I conceived this
event oh sure they could not save your
wives if they don't show agent listen be
told I know how to play this
that's what I said Dana role are we
going to see a new game after we met I'm
a TV dizzy this is your king but I can't
talk afterward obsidian June I mean the
bush is too dizzy to watch it put some
kind of xbox character in that so what
was the game what was the name of that
game Bush's Honey I Shrunk the Kids on a
baseball field
co-op grounded good Oh made by two
people
Martha Moss 24 forgot a date oh oh that
was the new character
[Applause]
well it's coming out on March 24th now
when I say an Xbox team it's like they
just they just point them out like to
sit right there right I'm going to steam
within that trail I can you tell us a
little bit about them yeah Cass she's
awesome she's our new damage class she's
a first fiber rid range Emily for the
game she's awesome at getting into the
backline the harassing the heroes she's
got these kind of augmented legs that
she can use to jump up really high take
out people who are trying to run off so
yeah I'm excited to see how to take out
the players they're gonna
deal with her in the next stuff this is
actually they're all like I think that's
all robot there see what demographic
they going with this guy great community
of guys yeah it's been really nice
working with them and we've got another
test next week where class is gonna be
available and she's available here on
the show floor too so people can play
her today
nice I think you did a photo bomb in my
3d games that's how we're gonna say for
me they're all gonna be Indies I told
you they're all gonna see them first
let's see them first
just looking spooky
[Music]
not like this XO not like this actually
there's a huge demographic of people for
these rollercoaster games yes if you
don't start with that damn yes
now you've been clamoring for this
announcement macho channel what el baby
log that into building but guess what
Lord kognito it's on game pass you know
what the new thing now is you know this
is our second team this is what they
wanted to do on the side why cuz why why
do you put this on game pass RT the game
[Music]
the console Xbox game studio presents
who composer who oh no I did
you just said that you didn't need to
say that again
safety decay oh don't nod those are my
peoples from armed life is strange 50
did they buy they finish each other not
to see right now read each other's minds
oh no one thing the narrative is gonna
be dope
whatever this is Joe they bought them
eating easy let's see they had to uh
let's see
you sure you want to go in there
addict didn't I say in a tweet that this
is a suggestion by right from the studio
that brought you life history I know
it's my Donuts was my dough's I like I
love this TV a few things donatus fire I
don't know if they bought this is
amazing she was never gonna let me be
it'll be on that stage after this 20
bucks though something to find something
that'll make it all make sense
they said Xbox Studios you may be onto
something we'll see I need to know
easy shock as I was saying to agree with
you
[Music]
the only thing that makes sense all
chapters coming soon oh wow yo I'm done
I'm done but we gonna talk about the
cart racing name for 15 minute with a
break then we go to gays for the most
powerful he's not wrong
[Music]
[Laughter]
you guys should have been pissed off
that this was shown at e3 yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey breaking this back this is a 4k 60
we've been waiting this is that this is
bad no no not like these great fighters
they better not break that game down on
fire oh let's get still well let's delay
okay so you want is x and y fan should
be so excited about this of course
Project X cloud is our cutting-edge game
streaming technology that takes the
power of Xbox and everything that comes
along with it and puts it in your phone
or tablet
that's your friends your social network
your save games your achievements your
gaming history all your progression it
all comes with you so you don't have to
start over and project X cloud can give
you this freedom because we're literally
putting an Xbox in the cloud just last
month you start the first phase of the
preview in the UK the US and Korea so
what happens next more games as of right
now it's more for 50 games in the
preview from over 25 of our development
partners
[Music]
[Applause]
the selection is little hotel make
rising so it looks like it's more
outside of game pass we're not stuck a
17-game pass you can see us continue to
add more and more games over time so
more games and more ways to play so how
can people at home actually get involved
preview is you want more ways to play
and we are delighted to announce that in
2020 we will bring project X cloud to
Windows 10 pcs right oh that's big state
is a delicious stared bushes right there
right there
they said PC that's all people were
waiting for a lot of people don't want
to do it to bring project X cloud to
every device where you want to play
let's go name put all OS and put the
coffee in stadium filled fake bogus out
of here of course plays great with your
Xbox controllers and because we believe
in choice
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's right bread and rice we be a
petty we view preview as our journey to
create the developers you know we're
partnering with the industry and true
Xbox style from you know multiple
industries we're working with the
world's best and that's content
designers and public stadia straight
pushes up for stadium and many many
others they're all coming together to
make it possible and I'm super thrilled
to announce that one of our great
partners is here with us today from
Electronic Arts the chief technology
officer and my good friend huge he I was
both talking about it but they
definitely doing their own thing and the
fact that they're on Xbox stage with
this they may be bending the knee or new
service projects close so how did you
get involved and what does game
streaming mean to you well the world
have more opportunity to play all the
games that they love
we've long believed in the power of the
cloud and that it's going to transform
gaming right at its core and that starts
by bringing all your games to all of
your devices and we're excited about
that where you can play you can play
with your friends even when you don't
have the same devices
and now that cloud gaming is starting to
become a reality
we knew we had to partner with Microsoft
on Project X cloud also so how do you
actually think about developing games
for the cloud well it's actually what
they do they service in the bushes I
joined the industry over five years ago
and and the VA but the cloud is is just
gonna be amazing its allow us to build
games in brand-new ways that are going
to be fundamentally different and and
it's my the only one that feels like
he's drunk so that they're available on
all of your devices no matter how you
want to play yeah our goal is to make it
as easy as possible for our partners to
build for the cloud when you build for
Xbox you're automatically building for
the cloud there's no extra dev work
required to learn about Project X cloud
that morning I asked my team hey go
install games on our project s cloud
servers you came in and we just jumped
in and played it was that easy
it was Xbox Xbox found something to be
great
so thanks for for the great partnership
but named some games for me ken what did
you play and what else is chronic arts
itself is one that I want to talk about
today and I'm excited to announce that
Madden NFL Madden NFL 2000 let's go
that's big that's about how to make our
players or how our players want to play
games in a streaming world we're looking
for new genres to bring we're looking at
a huge world and RPGs or looking at some
of our indie Studios that we
partner with to bring close to we're
gonna be bringing three more games to
expired in the coming months so yeah
they got the cloud they - the highlight
of the show so what happens after
preview so we're here today to announce
two things yes 2020 we're gonna give you
the ability to play the games that you
own from the cloud and we all know when
Xbox game past is the best place to
discover and play your next favorite
game let's go tied in we will bring game
streaming to Xbox game pass so that you
are what we do well that's our who did
that for you who did that for you
I told you is gonna be a cooler than
gamepad told you you can of course still
register the Xbox comm forward slash
game streaming get on back tons of
exciting things reproach explode Karim
Catherine thank you so much for being
here with us today everyone whoo see
that Paul what's the video I'm good
hunger have pause for me there we go
let's get the white gloves which is
already horrendous yeah Corey it's good
to see the homey black let's start with
Xbox one deal is you can get up to 150
dollars off Xbox one consoles including
bundles with gears 5'4 it's a lego NBA
2k 20 and more now that means the Xbox
one s all digital edition is only one
$49.99 the all digital edition comes
bundled with minecraft that's and of
course fortnight battle royale alright
but to play those games you need
controllers you'll be able to get up to
$20 off controllers including night ops
camo special edition the for tonight's
special edition
the gears 5 tape Diaz limited but my
Walmart always has them alright that's
great we talked about those we talked
controllers for the course we need games
now you can get up to 50% off Xbox game
studio titles including Gears 5 CFDs
anniversary edition Forza horizon 4 plus
discounts on FIFA 20 NBA 2k 20 legends
Edition borderlands 3 super deluxe
edition and more now finally if you're
an Xbox game past ultimate or Xbox Live
Gold member beginning November 21st now
Microsoft stores are a great place to
shop because there's other modules for
the $2 for the check no x5 for iOS it'll
come it'll come store price of this
season all right next up of franchise
you've always wanted on Xbox and one
you've never seen before take a look
oh you ahead of me damn it oh that's not
good that's good last gold up-to-date
Shenmue
[Music]
that's big that's really they actually
get into those markets baby
the question is how long place days you
had there's no just out of curiosity
oh we get zero to income okay okay pass
[Applause]
hold your kuzu on game fast that's big
that's baby big yeah you cuza
ask any games that you never had and put
them on game press that's a big deal
can't for now okay starting to turn
around a little bit uh-oh I think Apple
is that the development remember apples
a little bit more stringent with their
policies for iOS for arts club
I think that's improper they have their
own computing service as well I think
what it is they want to they want to
make sure it runs before they go to
abstractly Apple is very very specific
[Music]
[Music]
damn the light they missed their mark
Halloween has
[Laughter]
[Music]
why is your man's in the shot on the
right that was this is so cringy she's
getting attacked no much like who comes
up with this stuff
okay look when you announce this be
sitting down you give me a tattoo that's
gonna be fired
they better not show me no more games
that look like that super check final
hours to y'all because Phil brought my
favorite series to xbox he cools a baby
though doubt that's what our super chat
Jean Marco is you sooo good is Yakuza
trash now that it's good a game fast
ha ha you know what you might be uh-oh
oh it's reach times gauge
this was probably the best campaign for
hayloft you getting that PC Jimmy
oh man
I remember yes I remember the apps for
this yeah it was crazy man when it came
up with remember reach yeah a lot of
people don't realize how big this how
impactful this was in Halo like that
this is going to steam is showing light
on reach on reach like 80% of Spartans
were killed December prequel this kicks
off the whole saga of Master Chief's
journey before the events of halo combat
Evolved so whether you're an old-time
fan or new to the franchise it's the
perfect place to jump in okay more
importantly when do I get to play it
well we are close now December 3rd we're
super excited Halo Reach will be coming
the Xbox one and for the first time PC
that's gonna be a such a good time I
cannot wait now dream if I'm wrong this
Master Chief collection is an Xbox game
past title yes yeah totally and that's
not just on console that's on PC as well
yeah you'll be able to pick up all of
MCC starting with reach for Xbox and on
PC as well in addition we are now live
for pre-orders on Microsoft Store and
steam for the first time oh that's gonna
be a good time bright I gotta say it's
crazy man I was I was that kid that was
camped out here we are we come full
circle
you guys really take care of the
community and I gotta say thank you for
them and I know you want to give them
thanks yeah honestly we've been working
on this project for a long time the
world's waited a long time for him to
come over so thank you on behalf of the
entire studio everybody who's been a
part of our fighting program December
3rd is just the first step we're just
getting started we have a long way to go
on this journey but we're bringing all
of MCC to PC starting with Halo Reach
awesome well thank you so much Brian I
appreciate it now let's take things from
space to a little bit closer to Earth
about 30,000 feet in the air to be exact
it's time for the latest from flight
simulator place anyway actually a lot of
people want play there's an audience for
this house brother there's a huge this
isn't for me
apparently there's a lot of people
graphically look good unlocked
they said this is one of that like the
video that showing the behind the scenes
it's like 900,000 fought views it is a
it's a beautiful looking game regardless
- I don't do simulator I have to give it
that I know a lot of people don't want
it so it's good that they gave it to
them yeah it's been a longer question
for what I understand
remember they stopped making it because
of the whole 9/11 thing right they cut
it so yeah good point please please stop
making the game they're like
but its back
there's actually some really good
YouTube channels that have sudden winds
flight simulator and named end date they
take the role of the air traffic
controller and they mess around with all
the other players trying to learn your
tennis Eddie Lisa's not cartoony but I
feel that I feel that I do be feeling
like they do in too much cartoon too
much cards it's like somebody trying to
get that demographic I go for this and
why y'all that's an why right there
that's my city who gave it away the
Statue of Liberty for Kato Island New
Jersey oh yeah crazy
let's give a bit shy right now this is
what he waiting for
[Music]
let's go I'll play it it's on game pads
it's okay pass I will try it you glad to
teach me everything one shall stand one
shall fall I know we talked about age
for two years ago and then we were ready
really to start showing you real
gameplay I do want everybody here to
understand what you saw game play there
is what we are playing every day on the
team of the game which is the medieval
era and then the second are two of our
civilizations Mongols twenty years
millions of people around the world have
played it what does it mean for your
team to bring a new title into the
family of this this RTS legend it means
a lot of feelings the thing about a
generational game like this is that you
start to meet people who grew up playing
the game with their parents and now they
want to play it with their kids right
and so what that made us realize is that
we have this incredible community and
the love and the passion for this game
that we experienced from the community
it seems kind of limitless yeah and then
when we started thinking about Age of
Empires for and we're thinking about the
great legacy games we realized that
there are still so many stories to be
told in human history and
real-time strategy is a genre that has
given birth to so many other strategies
and yet it still holds true we grow our
user base every single month and we kept
exploring for the edges of like where
what is the limits to the potential for
age of empire so last June we announced
that we were forming a dedicated studio
for Age of Empires and today I'm excited
to tell you the name of the studio here
we go
it is world's edge world de France don't
have to wait to get their age fixed
right because today is a very special
day right today is an amazing day I'm so
excited it's the launch date we want
about an hour and a half ago yeah this
is the best version of Empires 2 it has
4k graphics up rest' everything all new
music sound effects we have a whole new
civilization all the DLC and eternal
quality of life improvements most of all
though what matters to us most is that
you the community that have been so
supportive come along with us on this
journey
so play Age of Empires 2de won't be
listening weeks and months making
improvements that you suggest and then
help us maybe Age of Empires for the
greatest new beginning for a franchise
ever all right Janet thank you so much
for joining us to get you started let's
take a look at that trailer where they
running it back
deaf get his whole oh yeah everything a
legend was born
damn right it was I remember playing
this game on ps2
Wow
[Music]
Jessie said her age - was this Jam still
out do anybody oh2
legendary games beyond legendary
[Music]
and it looks so good yes I cannot wait
now at this year's e3 we announced
CrossFireX
the first console version of one of the
most popular first-person shooters in
the world coming exclusively to Xbox one
in 2020
today we're debuting a first look at
gameplay but first we sent Benny out on
the road to find out more about the game
and the teams behind it for the very
first time on console only on xbox this
[Music]
to see how three teams came together to
create one of the most exciting
first-person shooters on the horizon
Margate entertainment are the developers
of crossfire international phenomenon
and one of the most popular PC games of
all time they're bringing the next
evolution of crossfire to Xbox next year
the crossfire X will bring intense
gameplay experience accessible to all
kind of FBS players through unique and
innovative game mode now is the right
time for us to prove what we can do
thank you so much for I kind of get
feeling that you let me win
they're experts at combining unique
world's remedies stories and great
combat systems I want to find out how
that translates to building a
single-player campaign in CrossFireX
we're implementing everything that we
know from the narrative side into a
first version military shooter who
taking the decade off interesting work
that's mark joining Studios on fire we
are starting to bring those life as a
single-player experience there are
almost hundred cameras in the space that
big pillar is that they're intentionally
so that you can do like leaning like
penguins or that's there to keep the
building upright ah talk with Xbox and
find how this all went down
we've got remedy we've got small game
move of course got Xbox how is that all
working it's art it's awesome my job is
just to make everyone's lives easier
what things in the game play out
should people be getting excitable if
you want aim down sight experiences we
have that mode available to Oneko who's
a help with the OMG over first-person
gameplay experience for most of the
players out there my trip around the
world's come to an end but there's still
one thing we haven't seen gameplay here
it is it's just a little taste of what's
to come
yo shout out Jacobs even - - I was super
check keep with a fire Lord John my
favorite part
y'all much love ya I appreciate y'all a
great turnout
thank you this actually looks good
though though fall on it no cartoony I'm
good give it to you
I had to mute the stream tell me when
it's over okay I can't I'm not gonna
have us get some strike because DMX
isn't here for 15-20 seconds I feel that
which I get don't get that copyright so
this has a campaign right yeah look like
remedies doing a campaign right a
free-to-play with a campaign yeah it's
over straight it's like a joint studio
project it almost feels is it over yeah
um
right they still he's still saying it
exes spittin bars he's still singing all
right now
sorry about the you guys but you you
know you know it had to be done that
copyright strike how are you feeling
excited this may go awesome thank you
[Applause]
but even more excited to bring crossfire
X next year to our fans so we're super
excited about that so on behalf of our
great partners at remedy and smile Gate
Entertainment thank you very much wait
for you all to get a chance to play the
game next year but thanks again for
being here also I can't wait for
crossfire X but next up a game our
executive producer calls twins picks Ian
check this out world premiere
did he said he needs more cartoons oh
speaking of which did you see that guy
just then I keep seeing him driving home
different girls
I've not seen whoa I might be witness
window manda the string keeps lagging
there's got to be some cause some
connection between the two is
appropriate to deceive
she got a bit of yolk like that I might
be in a Miss for y'all I don't know I
might be in our last hour it looks Allah
crazy as any pura I'm in I like air -
pura wait for night again
this the king of cartoons
what making the spot we're nice you know
they opened it up before night
Dork fire bundle Xbox games at least we
see that more often you know than we
used to
regardless with the games on my craft
choice D butter fold as we celebrate the
launch and show is something that hasn't
been mine crash this is actually this is
a fun game no this is dungeon you think
if you say buddy crawlers and I mean we
can talk a lot about the game but let's
just play it instead live here on stage
I'll just try to explain what's going on
so moms and Nathan are playing you see
their health bars or bars lower left and
lower right Tom J forced they hate these
little I said I think half the games in
the gym my wife of my son's getting a
say they work similar to abilities I
play this in the genre so you use them
and they're running a timer and they
have managed to do a lowest playthrough
this they actually enchant other mobs
and makes them bigger and stronger now
Momsen Nathan actually found a secret
most of the levels in my craft dungeons
are procedurally generated sometimes you
like bump into goo secrets and exciting
places and of course sometimes as you
have
we had oh they went back back back up
again someone has Donna - someone has
done it dad I'd see Cosby
so why of the game is that it's supposed
to be fun to play with your stupid
sideline boat stream yo someone's I'd
live on this is so cringeworthy it's not
like that it's like they didn't even
rehearse I think we could have done this
better Cognito Requena no not at least
resent kiddie games it's gonna be bit
harder oh great
as we see your ball these gays are less
taxing on extant and I won't say chaotic
it's a lot of fun so as you progress
further into the dungeon you'll see Oh
someone found T and T there I'll see if
someone can pick it up cool o TT
obviously you can throw that with a
giant explosion okay and you see all the
different particle effects and all the
things that's happening that's those
abilities that people are using for me
it's like taking some buckets they're
solving a puzzle no money this is not
Diablo
like the big treasure room that would be
Ivy I'd be stealing all those emeralds
but I think we're gonna have to stop
there guys for you J plus he's like
people it's not a triple ax is big I
feel it
listen Rick way or they try to get that
switch bag man let them square the
building Oh Marshall Cheerilee for PC
why didn't you tell us you know oh if
they do what I think oh my god sorry
mate we need a remake though I'm good
already
yo that's big they just won they wanted
me I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
in sequence to starting next year
[Music]
Kingdom it's gonna be available from
today
all right shout the G Michael Lewis
Final Fantasy trash now is gonna get
listen this is a huge having all the
Final Fantasy's on game pass is mind
blow like it really is Hades mm I'm
happy that's all that beat up three
months of discord nitro this cool yeah
you'll shout out to hide Lord once again
with that name put this out here for
Shaw we told you our discord night so
shelter hide in the chat it is smart
discord they put every final fantasy on
game pass with your friends okay just go
about to be lit ball PC with a gated
pass let's go
did you hear me no I'm not about to put
every final fantasy on game pass and
Kingdom Hearts 1 1 & 2 are coming to
Xbox fax Xbox I'll be out dizzy they
need to bring disco to Xbox unify that
ecosystem that be double is ultimate
you're getting more than 100 titles for
console and PC and Xbox Live Gold yeah
so you can play and get all the deals
modifies though joke which games are
coming to Xbox game past so let's press
play now
oh my friend Pedro graduates fire
rage eyes a big loaf
room different ashes yeah yes bein out
on Twitter earlier by silos principal
age a one dose final hole AJ Empire this
deaf well that's a Witcher 3 in Maggie
right
it is the witch of 300 no that's big the
winter is on let's get it Darksiders 3
yes my friend Pedro is 3x cloud-like
restrain that Yakuza all of them on cam
say I got a high of all the final fit yo
my ex cloud gonna be all that's me
and my back's not coming - browser y'all
to this let's go I'm with you drunk a
ninja let's go round it wasteland three
game passes so with the content is crazy
you can't put on the content I can't
believe what's yours on gamepad listen
oh my god I gotta clap again I'll escape
this tool bro you ain't see it in the
corner yeah is it over not eggs the
little sizzle reel looks like the indie
sizzle reel
she's a rage baby let's go let's go the
tempo I do it exercise let's go give me
that and I'm good to go
yeah Streets of Rage is that way
as you to rate for let's get it
xD I wish you I'm with you Brandon
getting Preston I playing @j for us I'm
with that and shrunk give me the Xbox a
purchase so you can burn stuff tracks
let's get it so Jeff I can't wait if I
excellent my blazer let's go they gotta
bring back shorty whip pop don't know
this crazy they always be making some
off-the-wall ball games
yeah I'm Emma Fox I've been around for a
while
so trouble flying I feel you but a lot
of people didn't waking a marksman a lot
of people with the Xbox system that
don't know about that life that's one of
the reasons you know March 3 didn't so
is good it's a big deal it's we're still
Haiti's in 2000 with Jack can you feel
the momentum zip it it is a little bit
it's a little bit my game passing an
x-file spit perspective yes from the
other stuff until less we guess we need
it we need to end this with a bang and
then they can save this I feel like it's
possible to save it now they end this
with some type of banger then yes
momentum solid right now it's an average
I'm just saying like all of them selling
I'm gonna play great game Jim Ryun
mothers shake hands and more three
months of discord Nitro and you'll rock
six months of Spotify Premium with that
alright now we've had an absolutely
incredible time here EXO 19 but we're
not done yet
[Applause]
this is what they're gonna close it was
easy to I was grounded not your King
knob what's that joint for Ninja ten
bleeding-edge is your king we both from
the bushes get to play the games it's
all about the fans and I'm just so happy
to be here with everyone in London our
biggest event ever in London is the news
about coming to mixer is there anything
you want to say about that oh yeah bring
an Ewok to mixer people haven't seen
that news God announced today we've been
adding more and more streamers he walks
a really special streamer and really
happy to have her come into slack a
small mixer it's a great community of
people watching people play video games
awesome completely great now we gamers
want great games and today there was a
lot to share from Xbox game studios
should fans get used to this what makes
was game studios is there even still
more to come
yeah
[Applause]
now games announce say just so minute
much of our first party work frankly
when we look forward and we're looking
at the shows to come I can't see a show
where we won't be announcing new first
party games there's just so much in
development and there's so few shows
that I think this should just be
something that we should get used to
seeing new games from our Studios doing
amazing work this dude could turn
anything to sound pause pretty quite
happy about with some major franchises
coming to Xbox very soon but what's the
number one thing that you consider when
bringing this third-party content to the
platform well we know our Xbox fans and
customers want great third-party games
and getting to open the show today with
Star Wars was really special I think
people know I've been on the plane from
Seattle to Tokyo quite often and doing
some work and it's just easing to be
sitting here at the show talking about
you coming to Xbox talking about Kingdom
Hearts all coming to game paths so for
people who haven't played those
franchises before and want to try them
they'll be in the service you can try
them I know there's more work I have to
do there I hear the feedback from the
fans and the customers about new
franchises that they want franchise you
can't help but to like this dude it's
hard not to like fail you show and I'ma
like them or do the hard work to bring
the games that you want on our platform
and they would have been watch them just
ended
we also heard earlier from Karim about
the expansion of Project X lab preview
program in 2020 with more than 50 games
available in preview new devices support
and new markets in 2020 what else does
that
Jamis here for us Project X cloud is
always about choice and like many things
this generation we're building this
hand-in-hand with you the reason we're
in preview is because this technology is
something that we're working on and we
want to hear feedback from you about how
you feel that's the stadia shot right
there right there the devices that you
already own this is about us building it
to the devices with them on the go the
thing that's really great to see is the
partnerships that we have you know it's
not just us building games it's third
parties coming in with over 50 games now
in Project X cloud which is amazing
progress we're getting good operators
like the telcos are helping us we have
new third-party hardware manufacturers
that are building you input devices and
stuff but it can only be done
hand-in-hand with community this is
something you know the BTS form is
multiple years from now and we're
working on this with the community so
that so what you want essentially is
people just to tweet you constantly like
I love getting tweets from people
especially the nice ones yeah I hear you
uppity Oh that's Getti come on game
notice to you Matt and I were working
through the studio acquisition map and
there were two studios that I was really
excited about as was he one is obviously
obsidian and we saw grounded here today
loved the fact that we can bring great
RPGs to our platform
I think we've missed that as a first
party this generation so we have the
opportunity to work with in exile and
bring a franchise like wasteland to our
platform Brian Fargo and the team just
amazing work and seeing the progress
that we had we said you know what a
great way to finish the show absolutely
and a huge thank you goes to you for
everything that we've got going on here
[Applause]
that's what they close the show any
that's that's not what we go out there
you haven't played before what do they
need to know well first the waistline
seriously I thought they had something
for a second you were desert Rangers
trying to bring peace and harmony to a
very messed up world only this time
you're moving to the frigid Colorado to
deal with all no problems but most
importantly it's a role-playing game
right where all of your choices matter
character creation creating your vehicle
and every conversation you have has a
rippling effects without the entire
world is through the storyline and how
people respond to you throughout the
world now there is a very long and deep
history for the waistline franchise what
can you tell us up to date waistline
three the journey is pretty fantastic we
we did the first wasteland we set out to
make a very dark humor role-playing game
with moralistically tough choices all
the way back in 1988 it was a big
success but then we weren't able to do a
sequel so we took everything we learned
from waste enum arts one of these coming
a game past two they just announced it
KYNA mar 22
[Music]
we know about geeky dude going at you
attic you say how the old Final Fantasy
games ain't dropping this year next year
there's only one final fantasy I go for
they mr. bolt but not having to remake
in the kingdom yeah I mean it's coming
we happy game pass me happy no I think
this is better than the average inside
expose dizzy I told my lesson with bombs
it's just the height they were giving
for this Disney after what happened with
the dude Chris Bailey they gave you in
my yeah that was like we call that we
call that blue balls at the end
they got us ready so escaped slave
wasteland everything was different for
still hailey mm yeah
Xbox doesn't care my playstation friends
they said because that's where the
majority of the people are at least no
crazy Larry we can be everything we were
in 87
I'm definitely playing this said Phil
was the guest celebrity
to be money said kids yeah go on I was
told right yeah but you're told right
about what coati Shoto like this is you
put this in the middle you don't put
this is - oh yeah this is what you open
it up with or something like this is
opening or middle height is this sad
that I'm so hoping for family you ain't
the only one I've been waiting for a
long time I it's funny as I've given up
on it blow it's the piss dump the secret
you know to see what I the secret and
everybody know that the best uncapped
secret and one more thing fortnight
fortnight sponsored the whole event
really you could sell the epic be making
that money man like they sponsoring
console events soon this xbox of a very
big I do they truly believe the other
sir we're on the Google hangout we're
not on the screen anymore let's let's
give some general feedback real quick
we're gonna start with kids because I
know how not mean honestly I'm I don't
have any emotion towards it because my
expectations I kept them low yep and
everybody was doing running with their
rumors and [ __ ] and I'm sorry running
with their rumors and stuff and saying
oh this is gonna be here this is gonna
be there and I'm like okay you know
Lucille questions would be nice you know
because last year and the only with what
kind of confirmed where my
I guess what confirmed my expectations
was when the Aaron Greenberg on Twitter
confirmed oh no Scarlett Moo's I was
like alright so this is just like really
the Xbox send-off show and when they
send off a console Xbox usually those
enough to console with like these triple
a quality games it's something that
sounds like I have nothing to expect I
don't really care what's coming to Xbox
at this point I mean it's one year left
before the next generation so I was like
I'm not really trying to be nice what
was that's what my stream was about
earlier before the show so where do I
mean it was honestly it was better than
I expected
to be honest as far as in terms of the X
cloud stuff the game pass stuff and you
know those you know EKU's the games come
in there's just like a lot that fanboys
and stuff that stuff like - all the
Kingdom Hearts I thought it was mess
with me - Kingdom Hearts and their own
game fest - they're all do we got a
rebuy him well you know there were local
being game passed for a couple months
like they're not gonna be in-game past
forever it was so that was cool day they
were they did manage to surprise lack of
studio positions though because it don't
I don't know like now right now it's far
today if you ask to be announced what
don't add no just please pass that in
like a five minute heyday it is an Xbox
game Studios didn't have the dough not
entertainment but it didn't really know
what those Xbox were publishing is it
that no I think they actually can come
out openly but at the end of the day
it's weird because I feel like if it
seems like they messed up and put that
there when it wasn't supposed to be
there like that's a future announcement
because like then why would you not
address that like why didn't at least
someone come out and say that it's a
it's you know it's the publisher thing
like they do with Ori why didn't they at
least address anything because that's
just gonna start confusion like are they
part I don't like had a breeze past that
at all but what else kid cuz uh
so I'm not gonna sit here
I rage and cry like I did for III and
patience for III was bigger I hadn't I
had no expectations so I'm like all they
got to do is surprise me but like I said
all the stuff that the the stuff that
would have hit harder leaked right I
mean even though Witcher 3 I knew
Witcher 3 is going to game past it
leaked by was like let me see if they
confirm it so that's why I wasn't
surprised when it happened they want the
ones that we're really surprising was
the Yakuza's to me stuff like that so
and again I'm disappointed because I
can't I still can't play freaking X
cloud because I have an iPhone my dumb -
oh yeah that's what you get for choosing
iPhone oh I really want to take
advantage of that you know but remember
we can't we get into coming to PC
announcement yeah but was it what
through web browser yeah my browser edge
or they didn't specify didn't specify
shot the bad big games rest in peace
Danny I'm with you I can't wait his
money you know that the whole like the
door shock comment is petty it reminded
me of when when they were talk about the
360 how they announced that you could
hook your PSP it was okay dude I'm not a
fan of like these uh the thing I'll tell
you want to that that it's tripping me
out there suppose of shut out the
element an appeal with the to our stupid
[ __ ] I was impressed EXO 19 with fire
you see at the end of the day I feel
like this could be split ways I don't
understand why people weren't join us
and I understand what people didn't
enjoy this but there'll be certain
events that the Xbox be doing that I'm
like let's all great it was it was
equally trashed but like I have to admit
like this is one of the very few times
where you know it came out really bad
like it was really bad dude they spent
more time on game played talking about a
kart racer than anything else yeah but
it's way better than EXO last year
because because like because of
excellent okay saying now like they set
the tone
like I'm not the thing that bugs me I
was willing to bigger show ever
the thing that shout-out to one second
shout-out to $2 super chair from stage
called tell these PS dudes to get an X
on a console it's a good kick to talking
to well grinds my gears jazz about is
the hey you know he's like they're bored
already studios new were to make don't
blame independent games it didn't the
city is like first like and like even
like rares this game of rare I don't
really expect much anyway but it's like
yeah that was actually the most
interesting game that looked in like
three years
2023 or something like that wow that's a
long time it's like that is that that
stigma is like man already got are any
of these teams ever gonna gonna make
like something that's like killer app or
you know I mean it's like even though
they make it a parent like oh we have
multiple Studios working on multiple
different products that clear and I feel
like they're going out of your way to
say that um but you know it doesn't
change the narrative that people are
going to make like oh they're making it
they're making all these cartoon games
at this very moment that's what they're
showing and and it's hard to not to not
agree with people on that like it really
is
mmm-hmm I agree what so that's where you
add less sound pressures and then we'll
do rating afterwards but um let's get
deaf and deaf until you know we know
what he's gonna say
overall the pressures of this EXO 19
where are you at that's a big pickup was
the planet coaster because I wanted to
buy down steam name and I'd be waiting
for a sale and I was like highly rated I
want to play this game it's coming to
Xbox and deep-ass okay fine bingo okay
Ben age of vampires soon as I sort of
like age of empires 4 gameplay
so clean beautiful she a game that she'd
really be waiting for this that is Age
of Empires is back I've been waiting for
it and I can't say I'm disappointed
and then Age of Empires two course hmm
slow-mo said 2018 EXO was better than
29th I don't think you're onto something
there slow motion oh we missed one shout
to game about race with 2000 which at I
can't wait to play yakuza continued F
then Final Fantasy's that was huge
14 is coming to Xbox only today and
that's something a lot of people didn't
think whatever happened well I've been
playing it on PC I can play on xbox then
you have the Yakuza's come in fantastic
fantastic which three everyone needs to
play that game now it's when it comes to
game pass if you've done and played it
play generation and then it was to top
it all off we slammed three looks fire
when you compare wasteland 3-2 how it
showed blast you mmm-hmm compared to how
it looks now
oh man they did tremendous job well done
to annex oh yeah no come on you either
interrupt you if you have more to say on
it Lord at it EXO 19 where you at
impressions feels or sucks I think a lot
of people were including myself you know
we expected III announcements at this
but at the other day it's still an
inside Xbox you know it's a little bit
more like an inside that was on steroids
I think on terms of game pass it's a
great show terms of X cloud it was a
great show but in terms of what everyone
watch right now it was a horrible show
you
it's not that this is a bad show I you
know putting the final fantasy in the
kingdom hearts to decide I regardless
how they feel about obsidian and
grounded you can't go you can't expect
its fans to resonate with having
something like outer worlds one week and
ground in the next yeah so and then it
goes for that term point where people
are saying that the quality of games are
going to get good value to accommodate
for game passing I'm sorry but it's
starting I'm not saying this it is that
because they said in there that this was
before Xbox purchased them true but how
did how do I feel about didn't they say
what grounded is also gonna be like in
beta it literally felt like a beta going
in to the joint like it was a little
strange I felt that that that
announcement I don't know I feel I feel
like this was a good EXO yes but at the
end of the day we can't mm-hmm it's like
kognito said we have to make sure like
we have that split thing now after this
EXO I know for a fact they're not
showing Triple A games at an EXO now
like I feel like these these lesser
Studios like the grounded the bleeding
edge they're gonna be the ones that
demonstrate EXO they're the ones that's
gonna go up there and show they new
games that EXO but I have a feeling you
know every studio has an 18 and I've
been feeling that 18 just their games
gonna be show to e3 right there's no JD
game of real quickly 210 on subject
here's what they accomplished they
killed stadia to put a shot across the
bow Sony with Final Fantasy everything
your cools the Kingdom Hearts and they
let you know what I want to eat well
switch with all the animating you know
what he's got a good point there JT
you're onto something because they did
do that they took all the games that
have been really attached to the Sony
brand for years like Kingdom Hearts we
haven't had one besides three and
they're like look we got all that stuff
now and they're like oh yeah kusa we got
all that stuff down guess what it's in
game past so what you gonna do now like
I had to get my off to that they did do
that people
but at the end of the day kena Mars that
day I feels a little too late that they
would have had that before before
Kingdom March 3 I feel like it would've
been more effective now I dunno they're
making more Kingdom Hearts so that could
be you know from here going to the
future they want to separate that brand
from PlayStation and Kingdom Hearts
where people just don't see it as a
PlayStation game a lot of people think
Kingdom Hearts are still an exclusive
right but you know this is this is the
the event that EXO needed but we want
bigger games we want to see what these
wooden engine theories 18s working on
what obsidians 18s working on I think we
just got to realize that we're not gonna
see that to me we might see one at e3
but you know I think it was a good show
I think you know obviously we're gonna
rating here soon but I think it was a
solid show and had some downs obviously
I was really disappointed - grounded
that did not look like anything I'd be
preferred and I yeah and I put like 28
hours in up in outer world so I was a
little just disappointed with that rares
game I don't even know why I was there
if it's like three years away but you
know I'm satisfied and obviously I had
like like I I had like wool when the
kingdom arts and and Final Fantasy got
add-ons because that's something as me
growing up I thought I would only see on
the PlayStation brand the element
appealed to our subject flats fights
ability is huge for a lot of the
hardcore let me jump in yeah man all
money I thought the kids gay listen man
here's the deal I told y'all I told keep
your expectations low this is XO at the
end of the day at the end of the day e3
is on deck I'm not making excuses for it
but I knew coming in not to get too
crazy and to be honest with my
expectation as low as they were it kinda
exceeded because it actually it started
off shaky let's just call it what it is
it was a lot of it was really we've got
them opening up with the city the road I
title we thought it was gonna be good
but then we saw that first game it was
alright that looks like something ray
would make but grounded
it's like grounded destroyed me morale
for a yeah again you're coming off of
sitting in you're coming off out of
world you're coming off this high
quality I'ma be real yeah I don't want
to hear about your side project that's a
huge video that is a YouTube video I
don't want to hear about some joint you
dream to make gold but at the end of it
that on si that's what I'm saying it not
that should not that should show that a
regular excess I'm sorry I'm sorry
showing us why they were for sale anyway
no other publisher wanted to buy that BS
true I'm tired of hearing about you know
and again no disrespect to Ninja Theory
I don't want to hear about the side
project I want to know why we dropped
the bag because apparently there were
games that Phil and I'm guys saw that
dropped the bag and you know there's
some people that love ground is gonna
people that love bleeding-edge those two
games are not for me
like at all I want to see how blade - I
want to see outer worlds - now I know
we're ahead but at least games on that
level
after you can't come off out of worlds
and you can't come off hell-blade and
show us this and expect people to not
think game paths father right let's keep
it a buck Sony detractors gonna say that
so that's just me they started off shaky
um I start to heat up with a little bit
of the third party stuff game pass stuff
really started to heat up
I felt honestly X cloud Loki saved to
show and turn things around like when X
cloud stuff got announced a partnership
with EA I'm not mind you yeah he's doing
what is it our project stream or
whatever it is they're doing so that to
me was an e been that was to me that EA
said look we a able to do this we're
gonna have to get with these dudes right
that's a huge deal Madden on that
service you again
even if you don't care about streaming
that is HUGE
all of these quality games and
third-party games amazing final fantasy
again I'm not the biggest Final Fantasy
guy but I understand the importance I am
Jeff and jenni this also proves that
they have over
ten million souls for game pass because
because getting all these games and game
pass cost them some yeah I do feel like
that that might have been accurate there
around ten million because they weren't
they weren't doing small games they were
doing games that came out a couple
months ago nadi if you took away from
even final fantasy yakuza they were
taking out Brenden it literally came out
it literally just came out of months ago
yeah we're playing that planet of acts
yeah man they had some good joints that
game def sing let's talk about the was
it the one with um remedies doing the
story and horrifying yes like i think
you know those are the games the base
one is see not i mean not just it gotta
be shooter right but you want to see
triple-a graphics that's gonna take
advantage of this powerful console that
we've been screaming so I think that's
the frustration right the frustration is
we know they got stuff on top but we
keep seeing Kitty little things and you
know low indie stuff that you know again
that's cool but we need to see more of
that higher quality stuff to get people
banged up about get people hyped about
the all-new like this acquisitions I
feel like the the one thing that hurt
this wasn't it was grounded like if that
would have been replaced like we just
throw the whole show on ground we go to
legal no we low-key gotten right like
wait we're upset with the quality games
that Microsoft is giving okay CDs
whatever that game was called it looked
like something rare would do so people
like you evens like that looks that
looks okay
but then we got to ground it it didn't
even look like an RPG so it's like wait
it's like what what are you doing like
you can't come out there that's like I
don't even have an analogy but I get it
this is the this is the pattern right
when we were at e3 what was that game
with the deer game that don't want it
they put they gave a whole segment I'm
just like and then you and then you give
more gameplay to the kart racers still
lacking I'm to sling why had the don't
nod game that we were all a lot of
people are excited for and your breeze
past that but then you get now you know
what doing in the bushes for me and the
forget grounded what was that below chum
Japanese kart racing
mr. I'm like fam I get it it's you
trying to get in your switch Mario Cart
bag I just like fam you can't give that
much just felt like a sense of timing
and what is gonna pop like they still
don't they still trying to figure that
part out I felt like the cringe but isto
needs to be improved
right like some time I felt like they'd
even rehearse it that much right people
multiple people were missing their their
notes and then I felt like the pacing
was good on some angles and then it was
like what on something goes like I do
feel like this is an improvement over
last year I know slow mo doesn't think
it is but you know maybe the ground a
gated cartoons cartoons good yeah man
it's too much people want to see people
want to see the graphical bliss people
want to see this power you know I'm
saying and that's that's the issue bro I
wanted to see that I think I thing that
heard it for me most was grounded it was
definitely everything okay it was my
personal sprint for me personally
grounded was the lowest part of the show
because when I saw grounded I almost
stopped the stream I was like this is
not is they already told I'll be I
already knew but you didn't know but you
know shot the dealer gaming like how
would he know it was some side project I
mean this is our little passion thing
now we got a budget with like at least
you know you know I guess it's to say it
is the same thing because bleeding-edge
is nothing like an edge after city and
has made RPGs and then they make this
they get him to lose a bag so you'll
finish your dream
[Laughter]
finish your dream finish your dream we
got you that you know that seems like yo
if you only go sound off you me because
I need to see more on it
maybe it's an interesting game but
coming from a fan that loved the new
Vegas is that love the outer worlds that
love the South Park that love the
Couture too crowded was not my thing
like with you bro the same way you feel
about grandma is the same way I know
what disrespect
idak salty because he can't survive in
survival he like round it no doubt you
like cart races - listen I'm cool with
that I'm cool with variety again but you
gotta admit element appeal and the
people who love those games that again
the pacing they spent so much time with
no not to read not been the games that
looked semi-decent not to mention oh
like come all pacing fan not to mention
there was no studio accusations so yeah
that's kind of weird not to mention they
put Bill Spencer out there to give us
they put Phil Spencer up there to be
like yo waistline 3s coming out and they
moved to him he literally did have to be
there like can we could we get to Dallas
in the room which is all right we will
all agree
look what's lane three looks good but
it's good that's like putting XCOM on
top of the stage ending a show with it
you don't do that it's a very minority
of people that's even gonna play this
game they started to get the momentum
back with the with there's cloud now
smash they started to get the
announcement they huge with the Japanese
stuff Foursquare came out Momentum's
coming back okay we get in all these
games that notoriously would only be on
PlayStation Network Xbox and ea game
past day and day we hide momentum switch
and you feel it so now I'm like okay
they could take an average two very
spooky starting show - now we're getting
somewhere
age of empire Bowl okay then we get into
the end and it was set up like I'm
sitting on my yo they may do it Phil is
here you don't say like if they would
have like that with the fable try
some unannounced banger is all they had
to say but you know the screen at the
end of the day you know we've said it
over and over kognito we said it over
and over again
I'm tired of the burgers and the fries I
don't care if it's not for me I want
more than the burgers in front well now
we get like the one ship like yo Thank
You slow-mo expose gangster is the make
of which platform make your dream game
that nobody ever want to play but you
always say always saying there's a bunch
of Kojima's making games they just
imagine them or God and I'm subletting
the amazing to make these little side
you know I guess as long as they don't
do this again with the city here I don't
even mind if it's a smaller project just
make it to what obsidian makes so I'm
starting it I'm gonna be real with you I
think don't I think this is the new wave
with a lot of these I think in the fine
print in order for thee this is my guess
an order for these Studios to they want
these your Microsoft him get creative
freedom there was probably something in
the fine print let my man's and them get
off I think I think the big thing
shout-out to JD game for the two dollar
super chat Phyllis flip just wait three
new studios are coming how to slip just
wait three new studios are coming where
did you get that from JD you could put
that in the regular chat and I'll read
it for Idol I want to know exactly what
you're talking about their button it's a
neck so I feel like for an EXO standards
it was good you know let's just go ahead
and go into the to the ratings let's see
everyone's ring kids move what's your
ratings I already saw it on Twitter
because you've ruined it but what is
your ratings because watch death give it
a breakdown wise a seven I take care
because I think I gave xbox III a six
out of ten this year so and it was
better than that and when you look at
for the forms of expectations look you
want to show with low expectations so
they either going to V Apple
expectations in a meet your expectations
like all right whatever no I I should be
I expected this I shouldn't wash it if I
was it if I didn't care for what I was
gonna see right
however because my expectations it was
was like very kind of bare minimum low
they didn't they did exceed those so I
know I walked away with some appreciate
I like and we cut game wise I mean I'm
not there's a lot that cartoon stuff you
know I wasn't really feeling but the
show I can't lie I mean I didn't have a
really problem with it I didn't have a
problem with them never problem what
they were what they were showing however
if this was III right yeah it would be
my reaction like this past June I blind
this is a five or six mm-hmm but because
of what it is I was like it wasn't bad
it was it was it was average I mean they
did surprise me a few surprises here and
there you got some stuff cooking in the
pipeline I'm more interested in s cloud
than I was before
I'm more happy in my investment what
game pass did I yes because yeah there's
so much games right but just doing there
that you know a lot easy into like you
know I want to buy do I buy it
yo okay I'm sure my song I'm happy with
game pass in yo there's just thing that
just popped up for my dashboard so I
gotta claim my Spotify had never had a
Spotify account but I get him for what
six months oh yeah that's a great deal
the discord nitro yeah the other thing
is the count but that bundle they got
going on is dope so a lot of good
information game rise note nothing good
seven out of ten for me I really got
nothing to complain about
but look them pulled this stunt at III
bro they pull this III and didn't have
the nerve good now Scarlett at the end
of it I'm walking out I think there were
certain sections that just that just
brought the whole the whole thing down a
one obviously was the obsidian I think
the cart thing was another one because
you spent more time on the court stuff
than you do your own stuff and another
one was to feel Spencer thing because it
made you hyped up that he's gonna
announce something and he just like yo
you know way
saying threes coming on Xbox we feel
real good about this pass it on to the
other dude that's literally all he said
and I'm just like you know you would
have just corrected just like if you
would have just corrected those flows of
the of the show it would have been
better I think that I think the pacing
was better than III yes I think the
pacing was improved I was yes so I'm
gonna give it a seven out of ten I think
the reason it's a seven out of ten is
because I do think the majority of the
show was good it was certain sections
was so bad it brought the whole quality
of the show down the bill Spencer and
they're sitting things the two things
that should not have happened because
you pretty much you have this this
library that you sold with obsidian
products and you give something like
rounded and you have no Spencer that
normally comes out there and announced
as good stuff comes out there and just
announces waistline threes on game pass
which we already knew that so you know
you get people really frustrated with
that and I think the card thing wouldn't
have been as bad the other two would
have been better right but the cart
thing you showed they showed more on
cart than they showed on wasteland three
the thing they aided the show yeah yeah
that's definitely let's get death man I
know he's got is a favorite game of all
time it was their rating broke my reason
okay west of your
you
all right what's wrong five seconds
now a second yo-yo hi let us know here
is now
Elia Oh yo yo yo my check
can you hear us now alright the sig says
good that was the play we solace
disagrees so a place to bring it back
cuz they thought that I silenced you I
was biased so 8.5 you thought it was
great you break it down break down some
what they're saying five reason the
first game that war of the Dead game
that has the final France has the 13
game that brings back so many memories
love the aesthetic looking for this game
for a while on Steam no Xbox a game pass
okay moving on all the final fantasies
including 14 coming to Xbox an in-game
pass with the Yakuza and Kingdom Hearts
that's a big win on top of that exclude
on PC massive win thank you but the big
when I was looking for was the age of
empires and Age of Empires for beat my
expectations for a good game and they
completely destroyed it well done to
whoever did impose to fire and then we
slammed three looks wonder great can't
wait for it sell me on what I'm gonna
get at XL 19 sell me on what I'm looking
for in my taste of games hmm and they
just blew straight out to the water
that's why I gave in 8.5 the old thing
is the RTS you know and knows are no
specific type of games for that crowd
that they hit that market for you they
hit though that target for you yet they
because currently because the got a
genre fella wave like this is no longer
huge battles of
like 20 different RTS games all there is
is civilization right now Age of Empires
has come back to challenge civilization
which I am super hype debates that gives
us a better civilization mm-hmm and that
is pretty much what it would have been
higher if it would have been higher the
name play 550 which it would have been a
nine if they had fable or fake triple-a
IP
well let me ask you this dead before I
let you go was there anything you were
disappointed with besides not the fable
at the end
was there anything disappointed nothing
jumped out to me and said oh this is
trash I don't wanna play this hold on I
got deal with everything was fire you
know knifing was fired but not
everything was trash it was made it was
middle-of-the-road
it could move depending on like that
obsidian game for example yeah let's get
to it
oh it's traps Lobos dude he said it's
British cousin from doing that you go
into these events was what can they do
for me he's not he's not really a
content creator because I feel like when
you're consecrated or a podcaster you
have to try to be a little bit more in
the middle ground
he's a consumer he's like what can they
do for me he's not trying to hear not
nobody talk that talk down I fit well
let me jump it if you fit is oh yeah
listen y'all
this was definitely less like it was but
it was probably the best XO for me you
know I um I think it was definitely
better than XO 2018 you know at the end
of the day you know um the problem I
have is again when Microsoft uses the
verbage they use the hyperbole this is
the biggest this is just you know you
draw you better not miss this because
we're gonna have announcements and
fangers that's when I got a deduct the
points from them because it's like when
you come with that level of hyperbole
people are going to want unicorns and
earth to open up and the Red Sea depart
that's what people are gonna get say
right so when we get that start that we
had was very spooky a lot of cartoon
kind of stuff again not that these games
could be terrible like we've never seen
but at the end of the day that's not
gonna excite a base who's saying why
should I go to your platform right now
yes to def fingers point age of empire
big announcement not for everybody but
big announcement you know I'm saying I
do a greedy obsidian drink wasn't let
down considering you know I thought like
I said once we got to past the crossfire
crossfire was good when we got to the
middle then it really started to heat up
a little bit for me you know X cloud you
know I'm you get raised to the bubble
now yeah rage to fire they did a
fantastic job of solidifying the
importance of game paths of what like it
is literally their backbone going into
that yeah that was the thing that it
gave me the most confidence this point
it's safe to say that they're building
causes and stuff to support game paths
they're not doing it the other way
around right you know saying but at the
end of the day not you say dude come on
call you act like they launched stadia
but they killed States because the thing
is the main thing stadia had was yo we
in a browser
there's ago we do that too you never say
and we got they were showing third party
games that Bernie
in game pass yet in X cloud like it was
tacking it was a bunch of games I'm like
yo this is use cloud library is already
triple of what what state already like
the smacking of stadium was just like
and he was throwing his [ __ ] phil was
throwing dogs cuz feels like yeah we not
like these other dudes out here
beta-tested you know i'm saying we out
here what we'll finish games with prop
the darts the subliminals he was
throwing i think google was crazy to me
like he was popping off there's no doubt
dan it was buddies if you look at it
from the standpoint he brought up here
he's like dave with us who you win the
day okay yeah i don't yeah i could not
like EA all y'all want but look at them
MPD's mad and one two months in a row
you got madden on the go it's a rap then
they talking about other different
devices huge deal so game pass x cloud
did your cool announcement fire so to me
that's when things start to shift
everything is starting to fly all they
gotta do is bring it home if they would
have brought it home I'd give it a 8.5
or 9 not that waistline with wastelands
is whack wastelands is really good but
not a show ender that's all that's my
only beef I thought it was a solid show
right they should have opened I feel
like they should open with the wasteland
right it was good enough to open with
right in that rare and grounded game
should have been in between yeah if they
would have just closed if you want to do
it yo we got one more thing right boom
cue up the music fable or kill whatever
it is that we didn't know that was a big
announcement you win yo bro they can if
they gave me even like a freaking um
trendy alright so say fables out of the
question are all they could have done
was show the fable logo and then is
young in the transitions yes what's
around it it's like and it's like let me
finish it all that would have to do is a
puffs up fable a blow
the fable music and then and then the
local putters around it's like stay
tuned for III the babe it will just say
or just say to develop a be like
playground studios or whoever it is
right and the JPEG overall I gave it I'm
in the seventh for an inside Xbox yeah
it was a good show but XO no it was for
the best thing ever and all that now
we're not gonna do that now if it's not
Xbox sister like that from here going
forward that's lit Forte said I killed
votchin evil after the begin here the
beginning was spooky I was like the
beginning was Paulie a shot oh yeah JT
gamer said I was from Sony tried to step
up the PS now Microsoft just showed them
the stadia how was done put a fork in
stadia and PS now game passed for life
and s cloud - I go Friday that was the
biggest flex to me like the X cloud flex
I didn't think it was no going here so
we're you know saying but overall seven
seven point five better than my
expectation but again they still got
more work to do and III now we don't
heard excuses right we heard you know
we're not gonna show favor we're not
gonna show let's other stuff because so
come III now right we gotta get the
beggars this is what's supposed to be
coming with scarlet so I want to see
you're not saying but overall you know
better than average show that that's
where I'm at chat is like five point
five out of ten five out of ten so I got
a couple questions we're cooking you
guys to chat real quick okay
let's go put your ratings in the chat
and see couples board you doing it put
those ratings in the chat let's see what
this is yeah I'm going salmon I'm going
I feel like they did enough to make it a
watchable show I don't consider it trash
I thought it was a good show but 16.5
still no reason to purchase scarlet I
feel you but I think I don't think they
care if you purchase scarlet any I think
I think their whole thing is obviously
they're saving that for a reveal event
and then you gotta admit this forth even
though the show may not have been for
you that like they had to
you confidence that game pass is not
fodder though like I felt they did a
good job of saying yo game pass for real
we got bangers in hand we got a lot of
stuff now for the PlayStation guys I
know what the counters gonna be thinking
back look those games we had already and
you're right but [ __ ] yeah
we got they had to pay for it there's
gex mark guys that's never gonna jump
into PlayStation ecosystem and get in
your kuzey and buy those games so to
have those games and the whole Final
Fantasy library and rage and then all
these other games dandy no that's a huge
deal they just announced it on Twitter
it's gonna be May the 19th you know
we're gonna have to go ahead and wrap
this up cuz I gotta go to work here soon
first off I want to say you guys better
catch this IOP off king is coming back
it's gonna have a lad to say too cuz you
know he gonna have first off you know he
gonna find a way to knock this up a
couple digits about prediction failure
don't get no less to the way addict what
do you think about the new bleeding-edge
character Captain mystic kid said had a
big bigger lower abdomen so you know I
have to see Oz to actually play the
character I haven't played it in a
couple weeks but now you can actually
invite people and play it with your
friends so I have to see there anyone
that's giving this a 10 out of 10 that's
your that's your perspective that's what
you think but I disagree but they said
I'd say for a budgeted bill no no check
it out your last words gonna be the mall
you already know with punches we'll be
hitting that up um yes Sunday's gonna be
live band please hit the realm 11:00
a.m.
all that good stuff man yo first of all
shots at each at 107 y'all we this is
impromptu I got a shout out my boy
that's my co-host Como's Lord addict for
putting this together last minute shout
the hi shot the Lords of gaming dotnet
for putting this up
and yo this is good man and to see this
type of turnout we think about doing
more these these live reactions it was
funny give it that like sub if you think
it was shows that was good
this was mad next time the next time we
do a live reaction I prom so be better
it would be better than it was here try
to make sure our cam pictures and suffer
in there at the last minute kids food
used to have a temp a template for how
he did stuff like this but I don't
exactly know how he did it so I didn't
want it I didn't want to learn 15
minutes work in progress man work in
progress but yes you saluted to chat
y'all gave us life today looks bad funny
we could charge a little bit more these
live reactions man these these are real
cool man but that's all I got so
everybody enjoyed them so we're gonna go
ahead and close this I appreciate
everyone came through we just have a
huge good good following appreciate
everyone know what they say all show was
better than executors appreciate
everyone that came through appreciate
all the likes all the super chats
it's definitely appreciative we'll see
you Sunday at 11 a.m. Eastern peace